okay so here we are and a local Chinese
restaurant I probably do a little video
because what's interesting is I have a
variety of exotic people here all of
whom English French French dhaarana
Jennifer and Lauren and Shelley now tell
me if you were to learn the language
which language and you like Chinese but
your parents because okay but you visit
your relatives in China they visited you
here
we were there as interpreters
but no what about you if you were to
learn a language what would you learn
and what we have in common other than
the fact that we're all friends is that
we're all interested in golf hi there
just got back for dinner and today I got
a fair amount of studying in I I'm
staying with
Kim Jung Hwa's podcast because it's it's
fascinating he talks about literature
and history and all the things that I
like but I of course I I understand a
little bit more each time I first of all
go through the text
you know linking the words that I need
and then I read it on my iPad and I
should tell you that I am now using the
new iPad the new mobile ilink app which
is a significant improvement over what
we had previously and I'm really
enjoying it and I can't say much more
because we're working out some of the
bugs but I can actually link on the iPad
it's just gotta we have I won't go into
the details but it's it's a lot better
and so I can basically listen to and
read and and mine all these articles
from Kim Young has podcast learning
interesting stuff as I go and gradually
improving my Korean so I want to talk a
little bit about this idea of using more
difficult text it's often said that we
should stay with graded readers and
things that are very easy for us a lot
of people like to spend a lot of time
with Pimsleur or ass email and such and
I don't so I mean it's it's up to each
person I find now that you know
initially when I went back to Korea and
I was listening to these grammar books
with lots of patterns and I did it quite
a bit of that and I find out
go back to that now because it's just
too boring it's it's I'm not learning
anything and you know I've only got so
much time and I want to do things that
are interesting and stimulating so I end
up back at Kim Yong Hwa's podcast
because I like I like listening to it I
like reading it and and fighting my way
through it also I was thinking myself
you know I have a transcript there are
all kinds of passages that remain foggy
to me I don't really understand what
he's saying I kind of have a vague idea
even after I've translated the words so
if I had a translation would that help
me and maybe it would I don't know but
in the past whenever I've had a
translation I've never I've never really
used it much when I was starting to
fight my way through for example Tolstoy
STOVL z' I had the English I had Anna
Karenina or war and peace in English and
I haven't even experimented some people
say well listen in Russian and read in
English you know and I also had an in
for check I had an english-language
version of the good soldier Shrake and I
again experimented with listening to
check and reading names but I never
stuck with it I ended up in both cases
just dealing with the text in the target
language picking my way through the
words listening again reading again
enjoying the substance the content of
what I was studying and gradually seeing
my vocabulary grow and my ability to
deal with this content gradually improve
because you know there's so many things
I would love to do would love to read
about so I'm discovering the thoughts of
Kim Yong Hwa regarding works of
literature that I've never even heard of
you know with check I did the the tolki
chesco mini los ninos tea
I did some Tolstoy some turgenyev when I
was doing Russian I followed the events
in Russia biochemistry so I'm gaining
all this other stuff while my language
is improving that's kind of fun to do to
just sort of stay with you know learning
the patterns and phrases and tables and
stuff I just can't bring myself to do
that and and I and I think that my
and actually is improving more quickly
now because I'm onto something that's
meaningful to me that's another reason
why I'm not such a big fan of us email
people criticize me for criticizing ice
email but I want you know when before
link we had I would use material like
teach yourself which had word lists
corresponding to each lesson well I've
gone through s ml for the content that's
there but I never read I never read the
word for word or the translation that's
that's there that's just my stuff other
people may like translations so I guess
all I'm saying is I'm thankful to have
found this this content and I think
anyone who is studying a language once
you get a hold of something that is in
your area of interest that's got lots of
audio that has a lot of lessons and you
can just continue to learn about
whatever you're learning about and
improving your language that's really
the that's that's that tie that's gonna
carry you forward and that's as I've
said before that's where I am right now
with with my Korean they only regret I
have is that in Korean they no longer
use the Chinese characters because when
I see these words and I see the Chinese
character that's behind them then I
fully understand the meaning and I think
would be much better if as the Japanese
do they still use Chinese characters but
that's just for me
Koreans are very happy doing without
Chinese characters so so that's their
choice so that's all I will continue
with kim jung-han and with regard to our
iPad I hope that within a few weeks
we'll be able to launch that so you'll
all be able to enjoy what I'm enjoying
right now on my iPad bye for now